let me get everything straight no no
problems anymore with paparazzi no more
no more nothing like there's no Court
docket I think what happened with that
the thing is is that there's cameras
everywhere
so I guess to be glib about it
unfortunately for him there were cameras
everywhere that showed that nobody
punched anybody right thank God and
that's why my case was dismissed to
harassment or knocked down to harassment
I say they said I'd pushed him now my
problem was that when he aggressively
takes this parking space me which is you
know that's not the end of the world I
thought he might have thought he was
gonna get close hitting my wife and my
son you felt threatened no no I I just
felt that what he did was impolite
bordering on dangerous because he didn't
walk up to me and say excuse me
I've been waiting here I'd like to take
this Spade nothing he just went this is
really fast and really aggressive and my
wife and my son were standing there by
on the curb - with somebody my neighbor
said would you like my spot now I got
every [ __ ] numbnuts [ __ ] in the
world writing to me online going you
know you don't have a garage I almost
picked up the phone and called you I
have a park place down the block
actually I like your wealthy man no but
I did yourself a driver I have a driver
oh you do I do
that's what my wife uses that car I mean
my wife you should never have that
because like my car yeah and was pulling
my car in there
do you love my car to go to Long Island
do it is the judge force you go like
anger management and all this kind oh
yeah does any of that work I mean it
seems to me how could he does what was
funny is you go to anchorman go to anger
management classes that would make me
angry when I was right well it's funny
but you're on something there right but
when you go to anger management you
realize you're not that angry right
exactly like you know I asked the guy -
I don't want chopsticks I want a fork
and you put the chopsticks in the bag so
I get to my office I open it up and
there's chopsticks in there so I go back
I'm like what the [ __ ] did I say - you
were in the inning he was going nuts and
you're like hey dude calm down
absolutely hey man chopsticks could be a
lot of fun
countless generations of Asians have
used travel [ __ ] American we had
before Alec boy you shut up
[Laughter]